oh
well thank you thank you to our great
president joe biden our great speaker
nancy pelosi
and a special round of applause to all
the senate and house members who are
here
and those who are not it couldn't have
happened without all of you working as a
team
so thank you very much
now it's been a long and difficult year
in america
we've lost so many in so short a time
but finally hope is on the horizon
and help is on the way
what what do we say to america we say to
america
help is on the way help is on the way
you will receive
your fourteen hundred dollar checks in a
few weeks
help is on the way people are being
vaccinated
more quickly and more effectively than
we ever imagined
help is on the way half the children in
america
will no longer be in poverty and help is
on the way
our schools will open more quickly and
more safely
than anyone has ever thought
we democrats made promises
we make promises in georgia we made
promises in the country
we said if we gained the senate kept the
house
and elected the president we would
finally
get things done and get us out of this
covet crisis
and we are on the road to success help
is on the way this is a wonderful day
for america
this is the most significant piece of
legislation in so many ways
in decades and we
are just getting started help
is on the way thank you everybody
thank you so much good afternoon good
afternoon in the rose garden
thank you mr president madam vice
president
an honor to be with you and to be with
the majority leader
of the senate chuck schumer i join him
in acknowledging our members who are
here
many chairs of committees members of our
our leadership because without
all of you this would not have happened
and it certainly would not have happened
without joe biden as president of the
united states
[Applause]
mr president uh i uh everybody is
complimenting us and i every time we get
a compliment i say i accept
on behalf of the house democrats and of
the staff
of the house democrats and i know of the
senate staff
as well they worked so very very hard
but let me say this about my members our
our chairs were dazzling in their own
work intellect
integrity imagination for the american
people
working with their senate with their
senate colleagues
i say their beautiful diversity of our
members
and i say to them our diversity is our
strength
our unity is our power and in this bill
our diversity to protect everyone
in our country to end the disparity and
access to everything that the bill
presents our diversity was reflected in
the house in the senate
in that policy but our unity on behalf
of
all of the american people is what made
this such
a triumph whatever differences there may
have been
shall we say as i say to the chairman
exuberance the leader
certain exuberances here and there we
all knew
our purpose we were unified on behalf
of the american people for the children
for their health
for their education for the economic
security of their families
yes this is a great day to be in the
rose garden
and to have us be able to fulfill the
promise
that president biden has made all
along that help is on the way
promise made promise fulfilled thank you
mr president
thank you madam speaker and mr majority
leader
and america the president promised
help is on the way and today
help has arrived help has arrived
for the workers who lost their jobs
help has arrived for the students who've
been stuck at home
help has arrived for the families that
have struggled
to put food on their table
and for the small businesses that have
struggled to keep their doors
open help has arrived america
this landmark legislation will get
relief to families
get support to communities and make sure
more shots get in arms
and i want to thank the speaker nancy
pelosi and majority leader chuck schumer
and all of the members of congress who
voted for this legislation and helped
lead
to its success and of course we would
not be here today
were it not for the leadership of our
president
joe biden
and i just want to say something about
the president
from the beginning of this joe said
we got to tell the stories we got to
tell the stories
we got to show that we understand
what the people are experiencing and
what they need
and i've been in rooms with joe when
it's just he and i been in rooms and joe
when it's just a small group of
our team or when the cameras are there
and he's the same person every time
and he's always talking about what do
the people need
and you know when the president and i
were preparing to take office
we knew what we were up against so we
started working on a plan
this plan the american rescue plan
and mr president from the very start you
sought the people out
you asked them as only joe can do
how are you doing you listened
to what they said and you remembered
what they said and every day
in every meeting you reminded us
who we were doing this for the american
people
and in particular the american people
who are hurting the most
the workers who have been out of a job
for six months to a year
the families that lost a loved one the
communities that have been torn apart by
this deadly virus
you mr president have carried a card
in your breath pocket with the number of
those americans who have died from
coping 19
every day he carries that card literally
keeping their memory close to your heart
you have grieved mr president out loud
with our nation
mourning the loss of so many
extraordinary americans
your empathy has become a trademark
of your presidency and can be found
on each and every page of the american
rescue plan
joe biden mr president you
had a vision you had a purpose
and you had faith that the american
people
regardless of who they voted for would
support this plan
simply because it will help you
had faith that congress would pass this
plan
simply because it is the best thing for
the american people
and you put in the work to make it
happen
to get relief directly to the american
people
and we've both served in the senate so
we know there's rarely been a bill
that's so concrete and tangible
mr president people will feel and they
will
see what we all did here they will
see the checks in their bank accounts
they will see the child
tax credits when they file their taxes
when they return to work when they
return to school
when they reopen their businesses when
they hug
their grandchildren for the first time
in a year
americans will see what we did here
what you did mr president and they will
feel the impact of this bill
for generations to come and that's what
happens
when you make historic investments in
communities of color and tribal
communities in rural communities
that's what happens when you lift half
of those children
living in poverty out of poverty
because of you mr president help has
arrived
and on behalf of our nation thank you
and it is now my great great honor to
introduce
the president of the united states of
america
joe biden
[Applause]
good afternoon thank you kamala
you know when i look
out over what happened the last 50 days
when jill and i first got a chance to
move into this magnificent building
behind you
[Music]
i promised the american people and i
guess it's becoming an overused phrase
that help was on the way
but today with the american rescue plan
now signed into law we've delivered on
that promise and i don't mean i've
delivered be delivered
look out there in all of you patty
there'd still be people
kids in poverty we're not for all the
work you did all those years
and i want to say to bernie bernie
stepping up and making the case why this
was so
transformational made a big difference
in how a lot of people voted
i look out at all of you house members
as well
who have made the case to the american
people why this is so important
i watched my buddy jim down in south
carolina stand up and talk about
how it's going to affect individual
people i've i have a
my inclination is to mention every
single one of you because
i think i've called most of you and
thanked you already for what you did
i even called pallone he wasn't there
though he was in the other side of the
river
we joke all the time he's in he's in new
jersey
i'm in delaware i keep reminding him
delaware owns the delaware river up to
the high water mark in new jersey
but all all kid inside i want to thank
you all
i want to thank particularly the speaker
who from
day one from the very first day
i got the nomination was supportive
in ways that are hard for me to describe
and you know i served a long time in the
united states senate
longer than anybody if i still there at
the time other than pat
and if i were still in the senate i'd be
senator pro temp because i was two years
ahead of pet
but all kidding aside we started a lot
of great majority leaders
but i never saw anybody handle such a
controversial
consequential piece of legislation that
was right on the edge
than chuck schumer i owe you chuck you
did an incredible job
and look and to the members of the house
and senate
thanks for making this happen you made
it happen
as i said i served 36 years in the
senate i know how hard it is
to pass major consequential legislation
particularly when we only have such
minor
small majorities in both houses tenney
you've done an incredible job
and nancy and chuck i have to say that i
agree with many of the columnists
that have commented on this legislation
what you shepherded through the congress
not only meets the moment
it does even more it's historical and
they call it transformational
and it really is the bill was supported
overwhelmingly by the american people
democrats independents and republicans
and had a strong support of
governors and mayors across the country
in both parties red states and blues
over 430 mayors contacted me many of
them republicans supporting the bill
and here's why because what you all did
with it and the refinements you made it
directly addressed the emergency in this
country
because it focuses on what people need
most
debbie and i often talked about you got
to tell people
in plain simple straightforward language
what it is you're doing to help
you've got to be able to tell a story
tell the story of what you're about to
do and why it matters
because it's going to make a difference
in the lives of millions of people in
very concrete specific ways
this this legislation everybody's
already mentioned
will provide fourteen hundred dollars in
direct payments which we all promised
well that means for a typical family of
four middle class family husband and
wife working
making 110 000 a year that means
5 600 check they're going to get
85 of the households in america
will be getting this money and a lot of
you know
because of the way you came up like i
did others what that can mean
think of the millions of people going to
sleep at night staring at the ceiling
thinking my god
what am i going to do tomorrow i've lost
my health care don't have a job
unemployment runs out i'm behind in my
mortgage
what am i going to do well guess what
they're going to be getting that quest
that check soon either by direct deposit
or
checking the treasury and they're going
to some are going to get it as early as
this weekend
this legislation provides resources
needed to open our schools
how many of you have dealt not only in
your own home or with your children and
grandchildren if you have them
with how difficult it is the mental
pressure and stress that are on so many
families
so many people needing need needing help
if they had access to counseling
because it's caused enormous enormous
stress
this legislation extends unemployment
insurance
by 300 a week until september
it's going to help 11 million americans
who were
days from losing that benefit this
association includes the biggest
investment in child care
since world war ii that's not hyperbole
that's just a fact
it's a fact it provides help for small
businesses to stay open
and you know 400 so many have had to
close
because the first time around you all
worked
and did a great piece of work in the in
the house passing significant
legislation
what's the first thing the last
president he fired he fired the the
folks who were supposed to watch and
make sure it got
in fact uh distributed the way it was
supposed to
we find out so much it went to people
who didn't need it
you all took care of that it extends
coverage
and lowers health care costs for so many
americans
so many americans and it's a big number
for people
it provides for food nutrition because
people knew and you all were out there
handing out food like many of us were
but you saw people
who were in car lines that were
literally
miles long you'd see four lanes of cars
that went back for half a mile each
just to get a box of food again
through no fault of their own it's going
to help people keep a roof over their
heads
half a million have been able to make
their their mortgage payments
about to be thrown out of their
apartments they have to make up
all that they owe and those mom-and-pop
realtors
are in real trouble it's going to cut
child poverty in half with
with and you know i've talked to so many
of you rosa you and i have spent
so much time on this but you guys you
patty and others are the ones who've
been leading us for so long
and it's finally coming to fruition and
the american people understand it
it pays for many of the steps we've
taken on to
to vaccinate americans we're going to be
in a position
where because of what you all did in the
past
we had the money to go out and literally
purchased hundreds of millions of
vaccines
and then go out and make sure we had
enough vaccinators
vaccines one thing to get the vaccine in
the vial
out of that vial and into a needle and
kneel into someone's arm
took tens of thousands of people and
because of you we were able to mobilize
the military
we were able to mobilize fema we're able
i was able by
executive order to allow former docs and
nurses
to come back and be able to engage in
this activity
and one of the things that we said in
the beginning that no one
thought that i was being straight about
was i said this is going to create we we
have to spend this money to make sure we
have economic growth
unrelated to how much is going to help
people
well guess what every single major
economist out there left right and
center supported this plan
even wall street agreed according to
moody's for example by the end of this
year this law alone will create
seven million new jobs
seven million
[Applause]
and the bills does one more thing which
i think is really important
it changes the paradigm for the first
time
in a long time this bill puts working
people
in this nation first it's not hyperbole
it's a fact
for too long it's been the folks at the
top they're not bad folks
significant number of know they
shouldn't be getting the tax breaks they
had
but it put the richest americans first
who benefited the most
and the theory was we've all heard it
and especially the last
15 years the theory was cut taxes and
those at the top
and the benefits they get will trickle
down to everyone
well you saw what trickle down does
we've known it for a long time but this
is the first time
we've been able to sense the johnson
administration and maybe even before
that
to begin to change the paradigm
we've seen time and time again that that
trickle down does not
work and by the way we don't have any
against
wealthy people you got a great idea
you're going to go out and make millions
of dollars that's fine
i have no problem with that but guess
what
you got to pay your fair share you got
to pay something because guess what
folks are making on living on the edge
they're paying
and so again all it's done is make those
at the top richer in the past and
everyone else fallen behind
this time it's time that we build an
economy that grows from the bottom up
and the middle
out the middle out
and this bill shows that when you do
that everybody does better the wealthy
do better
everybody does better across the board
if that's our foundation then everything
we build upon
will be strong a strong foundation
our competitiveness around the world the
jobs here at home
the health and quality of our lives
that's what the american rescue plan
represents
and it's all about rebuilding what i've
been saying and
bernie a lot of others are saying the
backbone of this country
the backbone of this country are
hard-working
folks hard-working folks middle-class
folks
people who built the country and i might
add i think unions built the middle
class
it's about creating opportunity and
giving people a fair shot
that's really all and everything it's
about
in the coming weeks jill and i and kamal
and doug and the our cabinet
with all of you members of congress
we're going to be traveling the country
to speak directly to the american people
about how this law is going to make a
real difference in their lives
and how help is here for them
almost every single aspect would be
significant would be
every if you took the piece of this bill
and broke it in all the pieces
every one of those pieces stand alone
would be viewed
as a significant accomplishment but it's
all the work you've done for years to
try to get us there
this law is not the end of our efforts
though
i view it as only beginning as we
look one of the things that i've been
most worried about and i think you all
have too
especially those of us have been around
for 100 years like me
is you've watched people lose confidence
in government
just lose confidence and then we tell
the truth
that's why when i announced i i quoted
franklin roosevelt he said i'll give it
to you straight from the shoulder
the american people can handle anything
if you tell them the truth
and they really can just give it
straight from the shoulder
and when we do something right we're
going to make a case for it and when
when i make a mistake i'm going to own
up to him say
it was me i made a mistake
and i said last night this is not over
conditions can change we're not finished
yet
conditions can change the scientists
have warned us about
new variants of this virus and the devil
is in the details of implementing this
legislation
i know from experience when the
president turned to me like i haven't
done to the vice president yet
and said take care of it you take care
of implementing
the plan but she could do it but i
remember
being given the dubious distinction of
having to implement
the recovery act back in when we came
into office
brock and i i spent literally four or
five hours a day for
six months i talked to them over 160
mayors
probably more than two or three times
every governor saved one who was looking
at from alaska to
russia and making sure that we're in a
situation where we talk to
everybo but it takes the devil's in the
details
it's one thing to pass the american
rescue plan it's going to be another
thing to implement it it's going to
require
fastidious oversight to make sure
there's no waste or fraud
and the law does what it's designed to
do
and i mean it we have to get this right
details matter because we have to
continue to build confidence in the
american people that their government
can function for them and deliver
so there's a lot of work for all of us
left to do but i know we'll do it
to every american watching help
is here and we will not stop working for
you
together with you we are showing it's
possible to get big important things
done
that's what america does it tackles hard
problems
and how we do you look it's it's how we
do have it within ourselves to come out
of this moment
which we've been saying a lot of us in
the same for a long time more prosperous
more united and stronger than we went in
that's where we have a chance to be
that's what we're going to be able to do
and it's really critical it's really
critical to demonstrate
not democrat republican it's critical to
demonstrate
that government can function
can function and deliver prosperity
security and opportunity for the people
in this country
and as my grandfather used to kiddingly
say with the grace of god the good
little neighbors in the crick not rising
that's exactly what we're going to do
god bless you all thanks for all you did
and may god protect our troops thank you
i wish i could come out and shake hands
with every one of you but next time
won't be so far apart thank you thank
you
thank you thank you appreciate it
ladies and gentlemen please remain your
seat until the president
and state participant have deported
thank you
[Applause]
i don't know how